[Music]
all right matinee show matinee episode
77 yeah so we got to Netflix's and one
shudder this week I just noticed you
know speaking of movies like new ones I
just noticed that I guess more movie
companies have jumped on the bandwagon
because I just got an email from AMC
Theaters saying that apparently through
their app I didn't really like look into
it but a bunch of the movies that had
either still been playing in the
theaters or had just left the theaters
we're now available for rent or purchase
like you could stream them somehow
yeah like birds of prey was in there The
Grudge was in there like pretty much
everything that's come out in the last
couple months was like available now so
that does seem like the smartest
nowadays don't like it only three movies
I'm not sure because I also got an email
saying that they weren't gonna charge
people yeah it's weird so that what
you're well I guess you're can just pay
for them individually like for the
movies if you'd wanted cuz I think that
they didn't want to charge people for
the a list the stubs a list program if
you couldn't actually go to the theater
so I'm thinking this is like a separate
thing where they're just saying hey the
movies that were in the theater are
available if you want to pay they're
like watch they're not gonna like that
what's gonna happen is am she's gonna
become Netflix maybe everything's
becoming everything that's why I like
everybody has their own so I mentioned
it earlier a lot of people gonna know
this but here here in Florida we got
some [ __ ] rich rich people mansions
and [ __ ] in those mansions our theaters
that look like real theaters that could
sit a hundred people they might have
that on there in their grounds they
might have a Starbucks on there on their
house on their grounds like a damn
compounded [ __ ] it's probably mostly
closed but when they have parties that
[ __ ] opens up yeah
anyway for a long time they've had the
ability to watch movies in their homes
streaming the same way they stream in
theaters did yeah well I mean once
everything went digital and yeah a much
easier for a long time think it's not
like you have like the one we love
they got millionaires and billionaires
that can leave their house and go to a
go to an AMC theater that's right there
in their house or right there on their
grounds nobody works in it
but it's got kiosks and [ __ ] [ __ ]
like dads you've got popcorn machines
and then go in there and watch a movie
on the day that it comes out in private
in a private theater that service has
existed for a long time yeah look at you
on a baby since it all went digital yeah
since it all went digital how much you
want to bet everyone's gonna get that
now
to where if you subscribe to AMC you get
to watch 20 of them a month you don't
have to go to the theater you can just
suck and watch more my yeah that's what
it's gonna go guarantee yeah and then if
you want to see extra ones you can just
buy them yeah right there off the app
and the on on the day that they release
yeah actually I heard the rich people
were actually the real rich people were
seeing him a little bit early cuz of
course they are yeah that they could see
him like a weaker they get all the good
[ __ ] yeah so yeah so but we did find
three new movies slash series that we're
gonna talk about so the first one I want
to talk about is on Netflix this is a
20/20 movie called Lost Girls now this
is actually based on a book by Robert
Colker and this is a slightly
fictionalized retelling sort of of the
Long Island serial killer case which we
did a show about not too long ago yeah
so so if you know anything about that
case you'll kind of know where this is
going it's interesting because I was
watching like some other movie or review
guys that I liked and they had reviewed
it and a lot of them didn't know of the
details of the case this which is pretty
creepy to me because Long Island serial
killer you know it's like what is it
like 10 or 11 people dead and this
[ __ ] is probably still running
around loose and a lot of people don't
know about the case so apparently the
book by Robert Colker which I haven't
read but from what I could gather the
book is like docu fiction kind of like
it's based on the real story but it's a
little bit fictionalized and this is
like the way it's written it's written
narrative Lee now the book focuses a lot
more like on each one of the victims the
movie which is directed by Liz Garbus
focuses on Shannan Gilbert's family
specifically which I guess that's the
thing to do if you are gonna adapt like
a book to a movie you kind of have to
focus in on one thing and I guess she
Anna and Gilbert would have been the
best one to do because it was her going
missing that made the authorities find
all the other bodies you know what I'm
saying because remember she was the one
who that the Long Island serial killer
if you guys don't know he's also known
as the Gilgo Beach killer the Craigslist
killer all this other kind of stuff so
it appears that whoever this person or
persons is has been contacting sex
workers on Craigslist and then killing
them so you know the fact that Shannan
Gilbert disappeared you know she went to
Oak Beach and she was working as an
escort presumably and she went there
with her driver Michael Pak and then she
like freaked out and was like running
around to the other houses on there like
saying they're trying to kill me and all
this other kind of [ __ ] and then she
went missing and they didn't find her
for like a year
she said they huh yes more than one
that's kind of what I'm thinking now
they now I'm gonna say if you don't know
about this case or anything like that
and if you're just watching this like as
a movie obviously because the case is
unsolved you know the ending is probably
not going to be very satisfying because
spoiler alert they still don't know who
this serial killer is or you know who is
doing this to all these women but the
point of the movie was to kind of focus
on you know Shannon's family
particularly her mother Mary Gilbert who
was a very complicated character but who
was sort of instrumental in getting the
authorities to get off their asses and
actually try to investigate this case
and from what I know about the case
because like I said we did a show about
it like not too long ago and this is
fairly factually accurate as far as I
can recall but it really took a lot of
goading for the police to really take
any of these cases very seriously
you know once even though like I said
they didn't find Shannon until like a
year after she went missing and in the
interim they had they had found like a
whole bunch of other bodies and for a
long time there's still controversy over
whether Shannon just died in an accident
or whether her body was you know her
murder whatever was related to the other
ones which I suspect that it probably
was because you know that seems kind of
far-fetched to like think that there
were all these bodies like in one
particular area turning up dead and like
oh one of them was it yeah it's possible
but I'm not buying it
but um so so the thing that's
fictionalized in this movie it you know
the cops are gonna make you very very
mad like Gabriel Byrne is in this you
know and he plays the Commissioner and
he's kind of sympathetic like you can
kind of see where he's coming from he's
at least like more sympathetic than some
of the other cops who were just like I
who cares they're hookers like pretty
much basically but as I said this is
based in reality and that's kind of like
the whole point of the movie is that
Mary Gilbert Shannan Gilbert's mother
had to pretty much like constantly
harangue them and her and the you know
mothers of the other victims as well to
get them to do anything because since
these were sex workers they weren't
really taking it seriously they weren't
really coming out to the media and say
yes it's a serial killer and I don't
even know if they've even done that now
like I you know I guess they do now but
so yeah it's it's a really good movie
it's like I said it's more a character
study or like a drama mostly based
around Mary Gilbert's character and I
like that they kind of had the balls to
portray her accurately in the sense that
she's not necessarily a real likable
person but you her hearts in the right
place and you know why she's doing what
she's doing and you can relate to her
doing that because her daughter went
missing and she feels like nobody gives
a [ __ ] about it so you know even though
she's very abrasive and she's very rude
and things like that but you know you
kind of understand where she's coming
from
now the interesting thing is that this
focus is very much on the year where
Shannon was missing and her kind of like
you know crusade to get the case taken
more seriously so it doesn't it it
doesn't go into and if you've watched
our show about this Long Island serial
killer you know that this had like a
horrifying conclusion as far as Mary
Gilbert was concerned they don't really
go into that it's just kind of like um
you know you know a little text thing at
the end is like oh by the way a few
years after these you know after Shanna
went missing and after you know the
investigation started and stuff like
that one of Mary's other daughter who's
portrayed in this movie is like a
younger girl um murdered her mom because
she had she had mental health issues
which they do address you know they
showed the character having like a lot
of mental issues and like being on
medication that they're not sure it's
working and you know they're kind of
they're kind of a poor working-class
family so she's you know the the single
mother is like kind of stressing out
because she's like she knows the
daughter needs help but she can't afford
to help her and all this other kind of
stuff
so yeah that's how that turned out but
like I said that's you know that's not
really the focus of the story they do
tell you that at the end but it's not
they don't really like dramatize it or
anything but yeah if you really like
true crime stuff and you're not
concerned about this not having like a
neat Pat conclusion because like I said
this is very much based on a true story
the director Liz Garbus I believe this
is the first movie movie she's direct
she's normally a documentary director
but this is a it's a nice looking movie
the acting is all really good and it's
like it's just a really intriguing
mystery story even though if you already
know the details of the case which I did
I still think it was like a really I
don't want to say entertaining because
it seems like a weird party his first
for this subject matter but um but if
you like true crime stuff you definitely
should check this out because it's
definitely one of the better ones that
Netflix has made so I would definitely
recommend it
you
all right now the second thing was also
on Netflix and this is kind of an
interesting I had seem like a lot of
people talking about this one but I
actually ended up doing it a lot this is
actually a series it's called blood ride
now this is a Norwegian horror thriller
anthology series kind of like Creepshow
or The Twilight Zone or some like that
you don't have to watch them in order
because they're all just like completely
different stories and they're not
belated the nice thing about it is that
it's six episodes and the episodes are
only like 30 minutes or maybe like a
little bit shorter so you can easily
like binge this in one evening which I
did yeah and I ended up I have to say
and maybe this is a bold statement but I
have to say that a lot of the episodes
of this I liked better than some of the
episodes of creep show you know what I
mean I was watching it with her that
they were competently done I liked him
um it's subtitled yeah obviously now
it's Norwegian lost a lot of times if
I'm gonna watch a foreign film I want to
be subtitled I want to be a want him to
be in the original life yeah because I
can't stand down dubbing sucks the only
thing I could say against this is that
they weren't very colorful like
trick-or-treat was a real colorful
looking yeah yeah they're they're
they're kind of modern a modern II
looking and kind of Spartan but they're
good stories I guess you could say
they're kind of like black mirror I was
thinking that too it's kind of looks
black mirror but not as high-tech is
that like that as sci-fi is that black
mirror meets with Twilight Zone yeah
with a little bit of Creepshow thrown in
because some of it it did have like some
gore and have some horror elements
probably more thriller based and I feel
like a lot of them maybe all of them
know that I'm thinking about it had sort
of twist endings or like surprised
endings now some people have criticized
they said oh well like a lot of them
they could see the endings coming I
think one of them I knew how it was
gonna end I was like oh this is probably
gonna be this than the other um but the
other ones I didn't really see where it
was going cuz I was just kind of like
watching I'm gonna enjoy and I've been
having a good time and I wasn't really
like worried about yours
one about the letting the monkey out the
box and the guys are singing guys
singing in English this [ __ ]
ridiculous song about letting the monkey
out of the box the monkey wants to how
did it go do they they eventually ended
up stabbed a bunch of people so they
were letting the monkey out the box
yeah the box but yeah so they call it
blood ride because the I guess you call
it a wraparound even though it doesn't
like have a plot of its own or it
doesn't like relate to anything else in
the series really it's just kind of like
a you know like a little pre-credit
kind of thing but it's just like it's
this creepy bus and then like all of the
people that were that are in all the
episodes are on the bus like you know
what I mean and then there's like a
creepy driver like looking in the mirror
and then it's kind of cool because like
each episode it shows like all the
people on the bus like all the people
that are in all six episodes but then
like it's the same but then there's like
a couple seconds of oh this is the one
that it's gonna focus on this time like
I said the the wraparound doesn't really
have anything to do with the rest of the
thing it's just kind of like an
introductory kind of thing like I'm
presuming because they're like riding
the bus to hell or the afterlife or
whatever it is they're doing because
they're you know mostly dead people or
whatever but um I just you know I just
liked that little segment it was just
like a nice little thing but it doesn't
have anything to do with the stories so
these are six episodes now the first one
is called the ultimate sacrifice and
it's about this family who move out I
guess they lived in the big city
and the woman burned through all of
their savings are like maxed out all
their credit cards or whatever so
they've been forced to kind of move to
this house like sort of out in the
middle of nowhere so she's not happy
about it so they go out there and their
neighbors are very um Stepford II let's
say that there are so like super overly
friendly and stuff and you know that
some creepy [ __ ] is going on and the
wife is like yeah this is creepy and the
husband's like yeah I don't know what
you're talking about it's not creepy in
the slightest even though totally is
creepy so um
this one is I liked this one a lot but
one the main character of the wife is
really unlikable so in this sense in
that sense it's kind of like Creepshow
because it's almost kind of like shitty
characters like getting their just
desserts kind of not all of them are
like that but a lot of them are so it
does definitely have that kind of like
you know you're getting what you deserve
type of thing because she sucks
she's like a terrible person I will say
that I'm not gonna like spoil all these
I'm just kind of giving a very broad
outline the very first one if you have
trouble watching animal cruelty or like
bad things happening to animals
might want to skip this one yeah it's
not graphic it's not graphic but just
thinking about it is kind of upsetting
you know kind of upset that was kinda
that was the point of the movie yeah
yeah she's a [ __ ] yeah she was she was
a terrible term listen cuz I like that
it's calm and I have a right thing if
you'll do it to an animal you'll do to a
person yeah it would just get it just
went to show and the thing about it is
that you know maybe the only thing cuz I
guess she was kind of a shitty person
from the beginning because they did hint
that one she was bitching about having
to move out to the country even though
she was the one that spent all their
money and necessitated them moving out
to the country so it was kind of her
fault so she didn't really have any
cause to like [ __ ] about it but then
the fact that she just immediately like
found out this thing that happens in
this town
that you have to do something horrible
like to get and she was just like okay
I'm on board like she didn't hardly
think about it and it's but you know
what I mean but I guess they kind of had
to do that because you know the these
episodes are only like 26 27 minutes
long so they can't like dick around or
her like thinking maybe we should do
that or anything because they kind of
established that she's kind of a
shitheel like from the very beginning so
like I said I really really liked that
first one but yeah if you don't like
watching even even though it's not
graphic but if you don't even like the
idea of animals like pets and stuff like
that getting hurt then probably don't
want to watch that one cuz it's gonna
upset you a lot so the second one is
called three sick brother z' and this
was a guy
who just got out of the mental asylum
for what it is at first an undisclosed
illness but they're saying oh he's sane
now so he can get out so they just kind
of show him and he's just moving back in
his apartment and his mom is checking on
him and everything's fine
then his two brothers show up one of
whom is the aforementioned letting the
monkey out of the box got me who I think
Sam is Otto yeah he was like crazy party
animal dude
yeah and they eventually convinced him
to go out to their father's cabin like
out in the middle of the woods because I
guess their mom is gonna sell it and
their father is dead and they want to
have like one last party at this cabin
like before it's not in their family
anymore so they finally like harrangue
this poor guy even though the guy is
just like you know his psychiatrist as
Holmes like hey you should do look like
not get stressed out and not hang out
with you know and you know try to kind
of like keep to yourself and everything
but eventually they convinced him to go
out there they like pick up a girl they
do like all of a sudden they start
drinking and doing all this crazy [ __ ]
and bad things ensue although this one
the way this one ended up this went in a
total direction that I wasn't expecting
like and this is what I mean by saying
that a lot of map twist endings the
first one you could kind of see where
that was going you know what I mean like
once the rules of the story were
established you were just kind of like
oh well I bet that XY and Z is gonna
happen so it wasn't like unexpected this
one I wasn't expecting it to go in the
direction that it went in maybe some
people who are maybe smarter than me
like figured it out but it's just I
wasn't thinking along those lines so I
didn't expect it to go that way um I
don't know if this was my I don't know
if this wasn't was my favorite or not
this might have been my second favorite
I'm not sure it's hard to say I really I
liked them all and the cool thing is I
think I don't know if they were all
written by the same people because it
was like a team of like two people that
put this together so they might have
written all the stories but they're
really different like a lot of them are
really so it's kind of cool you get like
a lot of variety kind of like the creeps
show so yeah then the third one is
called bad writer this one seemed to me
the most like a black mirror episode
because it has to do with this girl
who's in a writing class and then but
you find out pretend you pretty much
know from the beginning that she's a
character in someone else's story you
know what I mean
because even at the beginning they kind
of just show her being like super
perfect so just like a bad writer would
write a character you know who was like
super awesome because they were like
putting themselves in the story so you
cut but this one also kind of went in a
way that I didn't expect and it kind of
it reminded me of and I can't remember
what that [ __ ] I usually don't like
Will Ferrell but he was in a movie where
he was a character in Emma Emma
Thompson's story and I can't [ __ ]
remember the name of it it was a remind
me of that but with a horror element on
top of it so that was a good one tale
the fourth were the fourth one was
called lab rats this one was probably my
favorite if I had to pick this is
basically just like this shitty guy that
runs a company I think it's like a
pharmaceutical company and they have a
prototype of some new thing and he has a
dinner party for all of his like most
trusted employees and it turns out that
the someone has stolen the prototype so
it's kind of like this really tense like
locked room kind of drama where he's
trying to figure out who it was that
stole it
and that also predictably goes horribly
wrong but this that one was probably my
favorite cuz it had like the most
suspense and stuff then there was one
called
old school which was pretty much like a
straight-up ghost story you know where a
woman comes to teach at like an old
school that they just reopened and she
starts seeing people that aren't there
and you know that there's these kids and
stuff this one also had a twist but I
guessed what the twist was gonna be
which I imagine most people probably
would but it was still good it was still
creepy and then the last one was called
elephant in the room which this was
probably my least favorite although I
did like it it was just kind of like
this work party where for some reason
everyone was like a costume party
and everyone's dressed up like animals
and then there was like some kind of
thing about two new employees and they
were talking about like this one
employee that had been there and and
fallen off a balcony or something like
that and they're trying to like you know
slow
Finn like see what happens because they
feel like some of the other employees in
the company like know what happened so
they're trying-- like at this work party
they're trying to figure out like what
happened to this woman and who was
responsible for it so it was still good
but it was probably my least favorite if
I had to pick one now another thing too
is that just much like Creepshow these
are kind of like I don't I don't think
I'd call them straight horror comedy but
there's a lot of dark humor in them so
keep that in mind too like as you watch
it but it's honestly I really enjoyed
this a lot and like I said it's a quick
binge it's all--it's only takes like a
little bit less than three hours to
watch all of them and you don't have to
watch them in a particular order you
there's one that's a boring you just
skipping your the next one but I'm kind
of digging these horror anthology type
of things like you know I love that kind
of [ __ ] you know good yeah so more more
of this please so yeah so if you're into
more anthologies check it out if you
don't mind reading subtitles because
it's in Norwegian
okay third when we saw this week I'm not
wanting to see this one for a long time
I came out in 2019 I believe in
September but shudder just now added it
this is satanic panic yeah this one
actually for this week stood out to me I
like this one the best as well I had a
[ __ ] blast movie yeah and it seems to
be getting like you know put mixed to
positive reviews which I can get now
this is very much a horror comedy yeah
it's directed by Chelsea Stardust this
might be her first or at least her
feature-length debut I believe she was
she worked on a lot of different horror
movies like on the crew and stuff like
that like on the production crew but I
think this is her first directorial
thing and it's based on a story by Grady
Hendricks who I think is a novelist he
doesn't usually write screenplays that I
know of but yeah so this is basically
this is about a girl named Sam and she
just started delivering pizzas for this
place called homerun pizza yeah and she
and hold on the tone of this movie if
this movie had come out back in a day
Jeffrey Combs would have been in this
movie this definitely does feel like
something is right in this wheelhouse
I'm just gonna try to put that in your
mind first alright this is this is this
is Cano to me kind of like a classic
throwback type movie yes or comedy oh
horribly it's got funny [ __ ] happens
into it but someone's just really
[ __ ] gross and you're like what the
hell's going on what about a bunch of
[ __ ] Satanists and these Satanists
are like regular [ __ ] annoying ass
rich people and it's just it's [ __ ]
it's kind of hilarious it is hilarious
when it's supposed to be but it's also
kind of disturbing in a weird way it
worked it works for me I liked it I
liked the tone it reminded me of an
updated version of society the Brian yes
yeah yeah it reminded me it kind of is
not quite as gory as that but it's
pretty gory um so yeah that's all we're
at school fixed and it's all practical
effects I don't think there was any CGI
in this Fangoria magazine it was one of
the producers on this yeah
good and it's got a good score good
soundtracks got some music in there
that's [ __ ] pretty good I was like
man that sounds good I think both men
from Mars like did some of the songs I
don't know if they did all the score and
stuff as well but I really really like
not a real corporate movie it's not real
sanitary in the way that it [ __ ] is
portrayed to you you can tell it this is
a movie of his made with [ __ ] soul
yes that [ __ ] hard like I said the
one the woman who directed it you can
tell she's a horror person because she's
worked on a lot of other horror movies
is just the first one she's directed and
you can tell that yeah whoever made this
is having a good time like the old yeah
and also they know they're a cult [ __ ]
because like a lot of like stuff that
this satanic cults do like a lot of the
stuff that they say and the demons and
everything is like pretty is accurately
I guess the same it's they're pretty
good demon costume so I'm telling you
it's like a the practical effects are
for me they're the way to go I mean
they're always gonna look good I mean if
you do them right the first time that's
never gonna date it's never gonna be
like like old CGI that looks like [ __ ]
and it doesn't it doesn't look real it's
not supposed to yes your this is a
well-made b-movie that's entertaining
you and showing you some [ __ ] cool
[ __ ] this special effects on the on the
level like maybe like trick-or-treat or
something yeah like I said it's like oh
well Jeffrey Combs movie he definitely
yeah yeah like during like ones like
near the climax of this movie he's like
I feel like Jeffrey coke it's just yes
in a minute so this poor little yeah
there's poor little pizza delivery woman
yeah like ends up going to this like
humongous mansion and delivering all
these pizzas this her first night on the
job and she doesn't have enough money
for gas to get back on her Vespa and the
rich [ __ ] who opens adora of course
doesn't give her a tip because you know
how they do and so she is just gonna
leave it but then she's like man I need
at least five dollars like to put gas in
my Vespa like to go home so she decides
she's gonna like go into the house and
she like finds an unlocked door and goes
in the house and you
to get her tip because she's like hey
you know why don't you guys just like
cool all your money cuz one of the other
Pizza guys told her it's like hey I went
in there like got mauled oh yeah yeah he
tells this for like a minute I can't I
don't want to steal he tells an accurate
description of what it was like for him
to be in a damn orgy hilarious man
it's just yet there's a lot of really
funny [ __ ] in this so it's yeah so she's
s houses ad libbed which is even yeah
which it might not be but like but yeah
so this poor pleats pizza delivery girl
like ends up in the middle of
essentially like a big satanic ritual
and once they find out she's a virgin
they started like coming after her
because she's gonna be the sacrifice and
whatever so it's like I have to give a
shout-out to Rebecca Romijn who you know
she's fairly famous and she plays the
dannika who's like the leader of the
cult she is great she plays like a great
[ __ ] villain cuz like the thing about
it it's like these are all Satanists but
they're all like really wealthy people
too so they have these fantastic red
robes and like all their makeup and
manicures are all perfect and stuff and
they're all super [ __ ] like Karen
types yeah and they're a whole bunch I
feel like there's like power struggles
in-between like her and like this other
woman called yeah Hattie [ __ ] yeah it's
like super [ __ ] and it's just like
actually eventually at the end it's like
something off of a damn iron made me
miss dancing half nude or nude and [ __ ]
they hit they hit they hit every [ __ ]
point I really really did like this and
there's just like there's just some
crazy [ __ ] in this it's like I said the
gore is it's all practical effects I
mean you just see like [ __ ] their
their bacon like a [ __ ] heart into a
thing it's like somebody sticks their
hand and somebody's neck it is hard on a
soul I think somebody you know somebody
pulls out someone's intestines through
your mouth it's like there's a there's a
really interesting
drill sex toy yeah we called it a deal a
kill they drilled oh there are Julie
is [ __ ] hilarious and it's just like
I love it it's like those two characters
are only in it for like a minute or
something like that but it's just like
it's just had these great gags like the
all of the you know kind of the the
interaction between all the characters
like all the Satanists like all their
[ __ ] squabbling and then you know Sam
the pizza delivery girl who ends up
meeting up and like teaming up with one
of the I guess the the leader of the
satanic cult I guess her daughter so I
guess they end up teaming up now here's
the thing we were watching this movie
and the woman that plays Judy who was
you know the the friend that she hooks
up with yeah we were like god dammit we
just saw her in something recently who
the hell is that she was in the happy
deathday movie that's where we saw her
so we just saw happy deathday to you
like a few months ago to edit on the
movies really good there's no wrote
there's no slow spots yeah pacing at the
end like during the orgy is a little
weird but it's like other than that it's
it didn't really bother for me I think
the movie set up a tone of where you you
start to forgive movie for any kind of
little shortcomings because you haven't
fun yeah yeah man and it's and this is
not not a serious movie it's so
definitely it's an entertainment movie
yeah
and it's in its you can tell that you
know they understand the genre and this
is for people that [ __ ] like this
type of movie yeah and you know which is
for me I think that's the spirit of
those old old-fashioned horror movies
yeah it definitely did remind me of like
a tease comedy like a really well made
low-budget 80s yeah like like I said
like a Jeffrey Combs movie yeah
or like it reminded me of society like
thematically it reminded me of society
and the fact that it was like gory but
also like funny and like roll over the
top not a whole bunch of Satanic [ __ ]
tropes and [ __ ] stereotypes really good
yeah it's just I had I had a lot of fun
with this one like I said it's it's been
getting to like mix two good reviews
some people had some issues with the
pacing and stuff like that but I didn't
really have any issues with that I
thought it was a [ __ ] blast yeah from
start to finish just a really funny
really gory just a good [ __ ] time you
know what I mean so shudder has it I
read something on the Wikipedia page
which I thought was very funny that
apparently when they started selling
this the blu-ray of this movie in
Walmart they took the word satanic off
the cover for the ones that they sold in
Walmart weird so I'm like what does it
just say panic panic yeah or like a you
know can they even put a pentagram on
there I guess not I don't think Walmart
would allow a pentagram just reject I
didn't know they still did that
especially for horror Mike that Walmart
it's a comedy horror movie so you can't
even say Satanic yeah in a [ __ ] what
would you say that what would you say
those that's crazy those practical
effects range some of it reminded never
Naked Lunch something that reminded me
like something out of Naked Lunch the
demon costume is kind of reminded me of
something kind of out of member the
Guyver yeah it's good though man I've
seven good time yeah yeah Jerry
O'Connell is in this to like just
briefly him and Rebecca Romijn are
married in real life I didn't actually
know that yes but yes so a cute girls in
it yeah girls great bore like I said my
I think my favorite thing was that guy
getting his intestines pulled out his
mom yeah that was that was pretty right
you know constantly trying to show or
trying to set up some new trying to set
up some kind of situation in in the
story to show off some kind of gag
they're gonna do like ya know somebody
drowning while not being in water or
somebody's intestines getting pulled out
or cooking somebody's soul heart or
heart and soul I don't know turns into a
damn flying monster like I said it was
just like [ __ ] off-the-wall I
expected Jeffrey Combs to step in all of
a sudden then go you know what's going
on here they should have brought you if
he comes in on or he would have been
good as like the other creepy Pizza
employees though he definitely did need
to be in this yeah but yeah if you have
Joel Jeffrey Combs is now yeah I got it
you might be 70 by now God is he that
old that's weird innit we're so old
we're getting all yeah but yeah if you
have shudder
they just added this like yesterday or
the day before
for and I was really excited because
I've been wanting to see this I knew it
came out like a while back but I hadn't
got around to seeing it cuz I was wait
to look into streaming unless I really
really want to buy it or you can buy it
you know I'm sure you can run it
somewhere too but if you really like
horror comedy especially the throwback
type of stuff it's just it's just really
fun great practical effects really
colorful like all the costumes and [ __ ]
like that a really good great score good
music you know just a [ __ ] fun-ass
movie so
[Music]